hello everyone and welcome to another
very enjoyable game from day one of the
semi-finals of the ancient u.s rapid
knockouts it's alireza ferrugia vs
vladislav artemyev and this is the
fourth game of their match if you've
been following what's been happening
artemis won the first game and then the
second and third game ended in a draw so
here artemyev needs a win or just a draw
to win the match and that's it and
alireza needs a win he has the white
pieces and everything is up to him if he
if he can do it or not
to draw the first match so without
further ado let's check it out uh furuja
with the white pieces opens with e4 uh
we have e5 by artem we have knight to f3
knight to c6 and bishop to b5 the rue
lopez is on the board and now knight to
f6 going for the berlin defense as you
only need a draw it's a very solid
opening uh nothing to worry about here
we have d3 uh and now d6 we have castles
valeresa and the bishop to d7 so nothing
out of the ordinary here rook the e1 and
g6 now your pawns in the center are on
dark squares so your dark square bishop
should be fiance we have g6 uh and here
usually uh d4 is the main idea but uh
instead we have bishop captures on c6
going for this early trade bishop
captures and now c for grabbing control
of the d5 square uh next you're going to
play knight to c3 to add another
defender to your pawn and then at some
point you will execute the d4 to get rid
of your backward spawn so bishop to g7
artemia just continues developing
knights the c3 and knight to c3 and
artemis just castles and now you can
execute your d4 idea so d4
and there are two games in the database
for e captures and d4 was played but
artemia doesn't want to capture here he
plays rook to e8 and it is now already
as of move 10 did we have a completely
new game uh so let's see how alireza
continues we have d captures on e5 d
captures and of course not trading
queens you wanna uh keep the keep the
tension and get uh well hopefully as
many winning chances as possible so
queen to c2 you're going to play bishop
to e3 and at some point bring the rook
to d1 and black has to figure out how to
develop here so bishop the d7 now he
wants to shift the bishop over to g4 or
if maybe h3 then maybe even bishop to e6
but alireza doesn't waste time with h3
he just continues developing pieces so
bishop to e3 we have bishop to g4
attacking the knight here if you allow
this capture then you're gonna allow
black to mess up your your pawn
structure here and maybe it's not a
terrible idea just going for rook eight
to d1 uh but uh alireza first plays
knights to d2 he wants to avoid as many
trades as possible uh we have c6 uh
controlling this d5 square now also b5
not allowing this knight any any further
squares and now alareza says all right
you you've gained control of the c of
the d5 square but you lost control of
the d6 square so i'm going to play c5
and now i want to play knight to c4 and
get this knight over to d6 so this will
be very good for me
artemiev agrees and he goes back bishop
to e6 controls the c4 square so the
knight cannot land here we have h3 and
now queen to c7 finally connecting rooks
and preparing to bring the other rook
into the game
we have a3 at some point alereza wants
to improve his position with b4 to add
another defender here and now rook 8 to
d8 grabbing that open d file for his
rook we have rook 8 to d1 alireza does
the same and now knight to d7
putting pressure on the c5 pawn maybe we
can further further attack it with some
like bishop to f8 uh so here alireza
plays queen to a4
uh and uh although it's uh the the queen
is a bit more active here there's not a
lot for the white queen to do here and
here is one opportunity that artemis
probably would have taken if he wasn't
already up up a point in the match and
if he was just you know playing fighting
chess probably he would go for f5 and
start his expansion on the king side but
he only needs to draw this game so he
tries a more solid approach he plays
bishop to f8 puts pressure on this pawn
here
and of course you can't capture the pawn
here rook a8 and you've blundered your
queen
so here we have b4 just defending this
spawn
and then now a5 now of course artemia
wants to undermine the spawn structure
and if this is captured at any point
regardless what you capture it but then
you weaken the c5 pawn and then of
course the c5 pawn will fall so here we
have knight back to f3 and artemiev
just solidifies in the center with f6
uh we have queen back to c2 and artemiev
now trades captures captures and now
plays b6 if he can get rid of all of the
pawns on the queen side then his draw
will be pretty much assured uh we have
knight to a4 alireza now attacks this
knight at this pawn three times with the
pawn knight and bishop and artemis just
trades we have captures captures and now
he doesn't want to allow this knight to
land on b6 then if you capture white
we'll get a nice pass pawn here so he
prevents it rook to b8 uh we have rooked
the d3 algae now prepares to double up
rooks and the d file to put some
pressure along these lines and now comes
rook to b4 putting pressure on the e4
pawn putting pressure on the knight also
queen to a5 is an idea putting more
pressure on the knight than attacking
the pawn three times and the alireza
simply doubles up on the d file and now
of course you can't go for the pawn
right away if you capture it then you
allow this x-raying attack just captures
captures and queen captures on e4 uh
white now wins the game so artemiev goes
for queen queen to a5 this is played
with absolute surgical precision and now
there's a the knight is attacked twice
the opponent c5 is attacked three times
uh and uh alireza has to figure out how
to how to go about this so he plays
knight to b6 it's a very tricky move and
uh well now if if a trade happens on c6
then at the end of the variation the
queen will pick up the c6 pawn but there
is something better the c the c5 pawn is
hanging so of course artemis captures it
he plays knight captures on c5 and uh he
wants to know what uh what can alireza
do here uh the knight is hanging i've
just won a pawn so what is alireza's
plan here but alireza is incredibly
tricky he plays rook to d8 he says all
right you capture my knight i'm gonna
capture your rook and it's a very very
tricky position there's basically only
one move that uh
retains all of this advantage for
artemiev but it's not an easy one to
spot so feel free to pause the video and
try to find this idea for black while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
seemingly unspottable idea and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's king to f7 yes who who would play
this i know but it's the move that
really uh
just defends the rook and uh keeps
asking what are you going to do with
your knight here so there really
isn't anything better you're going to
trade here captures captures and now
what
what's happening with this knight here
uh probably we would see something like
rook to c1 where everything just gets
traded off the board queen captures on
b6 bishop captures we have bishop
captures queen captures on c5 queen
captures rook captures and now after all
of this capture festing uh we have king
to d7 that's why king f7 here here now
the pawn is nicely protected and now
you're going to enjoy your past pawn you
have a rook and bishop against the rook
and knight and you have excellent
winning chances so this is what artemis
should have gone for he played the rook
captures on d8 and this simply will not
do uh rook captures on d8 alireza says
you still can't capture my knight here
because if you capture it then i have
this beautiful rook captures an f8 move
and then after king captures
even queen captures and c5 would check
now the black queen is attacked here so
the queen has the capture we capture
again with check and now the rook will
fall king will move bishop captures here
and we're up a full knight of course we
are going to win this game uh so after
rook capture 78 artemis said uh all
right obviously this this will not do i
play knight to b7 now i put pressure on
your rook and i've moved the knight here
so you can start capturing anything on
c5 but the position is now completely
lost so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the absolute
strongest move for alireza while i give
you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it uh congratulations on finding uh
either rook captures an f8 this is uh
perfectly fine uh
it will win you the game but an even
stronger one is rook to a8 and the queen
here doesn't have anywhere to go uh the
problem is uh
if you play something like queen to b5
which is the only square then bishop to
h6 this was actually the real threat not
an attack on the queen and there's no
defense against this just rook captures
an f8 and it's game over another thing
you could try is rook to c4 trying to
get white to maybe capture with the
knight and then you pick up the rook but
the white will just play queen to d1 and
again the queen is attacked bishop to h6
is coming there's uh it's impossible to
parry both threats so here after rook to
a8 uh artemis said all right there's
really nothing better i'm gonna capture
on b6
and give up the queen for two pieces so
we have uh bishop captures on b6 rook
captures on b6 and now uh it's uh well
it's maybe a playable position because
uh artemis has two bishops uh and this
beautiful passport for the queen and if
you remember if you remember my coverage
of the
1971 candidates matches between bobby
fischer and ben larson uh then you
probably remember what a bishop fair and
the past pawn can do against the queen
but this is not just a queen against the
bishop here in the past pawn there's the
rook here that's incredibly active and
also this knight will also have a few
things to say so knight to d2
and now king to g7 unpinning here we
have knight to c4 shifting the knight
over to e3 and rook to b for now
we have knight back to e3 and now comes
rook to b6 if you start pushing right
away then white can easily play rook a6
put pressure on the bishop and once
black moves it we're just going to play
rook to c6 and we're going to have our
own rook behind enemies past pawn and
that's not the way you push past pawns
so after knight to e3 we have rook to b6
trying to
prevent this maybe c5 next maybe we can
get our own rook behind the pass pawn
and of course if knight back to c4 then
our timing would be very happy to repeat
the moves but here alireza says uh no
i'm just going to win this straight on
and that's knight to d5 and this is just
beautiful the knight cannot be captured
with the pawn if you do this then queen
the c7 check picks up the rook and it's
game over so artemis played bishop
captures on d5 but now e captures and
again capturing is impossible so c5 was
played trying to get this rook to c6
moving if you can get this in and start
pushing your pawn then you have you know
some chances but queen to a4 of course
alireza prevents this uh we have knight
to d6 and of course this check is coming
also very unpleasant so knight here
preparing knight back to f7 to try and
defend everything but simply queen to d7
check and you can't move the king or you
lose the bishop here uh if you try
something like king tj then bishop queen
to e7 is winning there's no defense
against this so here artemiev tried his
last move knight to f7 but here alireza
just piled up on the knight played rook
to a7 and he was in this position on
move 40 that vladislav artemyev resigned
to the game and alireza equalizes the
match so everything will be decided
today in the second match or maybe in
the tie breaks we'll see what happens
but an incredible comeback by alireza
with the white pieces in this last last
game of the match so artemia played
incredible chess here most of his moves
were the absolute top moves recommended
by the engine but the the only problem
martin had here i believe is that uh he
was playing to win the match not to the
game and that was his downfall if he uh
you know played his usual aggressive
style he he
maybe that f5 move that we discussed
when alireza misplaced his queen on a4
which is something he probably would
have played if the match just started
out would have been enough so sometimes
when you need a draw you have to play
incredible fighting chess and then if
your opponent does the same you're going
to get a draw or you're going to win the
game but if you try to draw the game
you will you will sometimes lose
uh so
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
we're not gonna be covering the first
match between levon and magnus as those
games were uh well uh pretty much quick
draws not quick draws but uh nothing you
know like this was happening there so i
decided to skip the first match uh uh
you know to to show these fighting games
uh so yeah once again i really hope you
guys enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
heiden queenie aditya parasarati
christopher alexander sopa tom derelo
and kkdfi.com for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
incredible event checking up in your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world thank you all
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day